minable besogne sans cervelle que
faites-vous encore ainsi sur vos culs
mal trempera qu'attendez vous pour vous
mettre en marche
il est temps de sauver l'empiré club
sciences carton de faire tu parleras
quand tu auras compris ta vraie nature
écoutez un crâne tre écouter le destin
que le ciel vous assigne gloire et
fortune pour vous tous hommes et femmes
remarquables
vous devez protéger le prince du anisi
présent de gao oreilles coupées le
meurtrier qui a usurpé le trône
écoutez le destin que le ciel nous
assigne vous pensez les convaincre les
insultant fais moi confiance
ils sont déjà pratiquement conquis dis
donc guillaume tu sais qu'on était en
train de dîner là vous très vite bien
volontiers mais faudrait voir arrêter de
briller
oh
iad où je suis en bleu parfait connaître
c est non vraiment si nous dépêchons
nous il faut pas et ça qu'est ce que
c'est que sort quoi sa basse heures il
sort du bleu quand je parle
vous voyez pas excusez moi j'avais pas
vu enfin je vais dire j'ai l'habitude le
bleu ce doit être un effet secondaire de
la potion que je t'ai donné pour te
guérir du poison
ça ne devrait pas durer bon il faut se
dépêcher comment c'est du poison
vous m'avez donné du poison non une
potion je t'ai donné une potion le
poison sega ou quittent la donne et gao
le régent gao
vous êtes vous